Okay.
Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Hallo, schön.
Nalan ist mein Name.
Nalan?
Frau Doktor?
Polat.
Frau Doktor Polat.
Genau.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als erstens tätig und würde gerne mit denen eine Annahme
mit einer Verstandenerin kommen.
Sie sind zusammen mit einer Verstandenerin.
Ja, wenn Sie mir helfen.
Ja, ich helfe dir.
Ich helfe Ihnen.
Ja, okay, danke.
Bitte schön.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, können Sie bitte noch eine Bescheid geben.
Einmal bescheid.
Okay, gut.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Bescheid sprechen,
Sie nennen Ihre persönlichen Daten.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Otto Hahn.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vorname und Nachname bestabieren?
Mein Vorname Otto wird geschrieben Otto Theodor Theodor Otto.
Ja.
Mein Nachname wird geschrieben Heinrich Anton Heinrich Nordpol Hahn.
Heinrich Anton Heinrich Nordpol.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Hahn.
Ja.
Hab ich richtig ausgesprochen?
Ja, danke.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 73 Jahre alt.
Am 15. April 1949.
1949.
Okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 86 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,72 m.
Okay.
Wo wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne in Frankfurt.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Hahn.
Was fürst du zu uns?
Wie kann ich helfen?
Und zwar folgendes.
Ich habe seit ca. 6 Monaten Schmerzen in meinem rechten Kniegelenk.
Ja.
Die seit einer Woche deutlich zugenommen haben.
Ich habe die Schmerzen meines rechten Kniegelenkes.
Okay.
Haben Sie, gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Das hat vor ungefähr halben Jahr angefangen.
Also ich bin nicht irgendwie gestürzt oder irgendwie was Besonderes gewesen.
Das hat so immer so leicht angefangen.
Das hat so viel Schmerz.
Es sind immer wieder kerrende Schmerzen.
Dann habe ich mal von meiner Frau Profin genommen.
Die hat so Tabletten.
Da war abends mal gut.
Dann kamen die Schmerzen wieder.
Aber jetzt seit einer Woche habe ich stetige Schmerzen.
Dauernd durchschmerzen.
Besonders, wenn ich mehr belaste, mehr laufe.
Wenn ich jetzt einen schönen Spaziergang mache mit meiner Frau.
Eine Stecklaufe, die ungefähr ein Kilometer ist.
Dann habe ich Schmerzen im Knie.
Dann an dem Abend arbeitet mein Knie, würde ich sagen.
Aber wenn Sie sitzen oder gegen die Schmerzen,
ist es in der Zeit?
Also wenn ich an dem Tag zum Beispiel ein Kilometer oder eine halbe Stunde
laufe, dann habe ich Schmerzen.
Aber auch nachts tut es mir weh.
Das dauert so ein, zwei Tage.
Dann geht es wieder.
Aber jetzt seit einer Woche hört die Schmerzen nicht auf.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich belaste, tut es weh.
Also in der einen Woche tut es mir eigentlich fast immer weh.
Haben Sie bei meinen Schwellungen in diesem Gebiet?
Ja, mein Kniegelenk rechts ist geschwollen.
Ist diese Schwellung schmerzhaft?
Ja, es drückt.
Ich kann mein Knie nicht richtig beugen.
Also ich kann mein Knie beugen, aber ab 90 Grad tut es weh.
Dann denke ich, mein Knie platzt.
Ich habe ein Druckgefühl.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen verschtegen oder verlinkt?
Sie haben gerade erwähnt, wenn Sie lange Zeit laufen.
Laufen?
Dann verschtegen Sie die Schmerzen einmal,
bei Belastung, zum Beispiel auch wenn ich treppen laufe.
Wenn ich jetzt ein, zwei Etagen laufe, habe ich Probleme damit.
Es geht schwierig.
Okay.
Bei drückenlaufe, bei langen Stricken gehen.
Manchmal, wenn ich aufstehen möchte alleine, dann tut es weh.
Und ich habe Probleme, das Kniegelenk immer zu benutzen, zu bewegen.
Ich habe diese 5-Wertige schon einmal für Sie.
Also in den langen Jahren, die ich gelebt habe,
hab ich mal geschmerzen gehabt, aber das war ein, zwei Tage,
und dann war es mal weg.
Aber seit halbem Jahr ist es immer wieder das Problem.
Wiederkerrend.
Und seit einer Woche ist es Dauerschmerz.
Die Dauerschmerzen werden, wenn ich belaste, noch schlimmer.
Wenn ich nicht belaste, ist trotzdem der Schmerz da.
Wenn ich aufstehe, wenn ich jetzt nichts mache,
Ruherschmerz habe ich nicht.
Also wenn ich nichts mache, ein Tag mal zu Hause bin,
dann habe ich nur Schmerzen, wenn ich laufe.
Da ist kein Ruherschmerz.
Aber wenn ich lange Stricken laufe, dann habe ich auch danach
auch Ruherschmerz.
Dann muss ich Medikamente nehmen.
Dann geht das wieder.
Sie haben, Sie meinen,
diese Schmerzen belastungsabhängig sind.
Genau.
Die Schmerzen sind belastungsabhängig.
Ja, hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Unfall hat ich nicht gehabt.
Nein.
Nicht, dass ich mich erinnern kann.
Okay.
Wie wichtig sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkoller,
wobei ein sehr leichtes und zehn sehr steigende Sprich.
Ich sage mal, 8 habe ich.
Sehr hoch.
Bei Belastung, wenn ich jetzt nichts mache,
dann habe ich beim Sieg keine große Schmerzen.
Nur bei Belastung, wenn ich aufstehen will, wenn ich laufe,
nur wenn ich längere Stärke laufe,
dann ist es ein stetiger Schmerz, ein Dauerschmerz.
Wenn ich sehr viel belastet, dann dauert es lange, bis es überkommt.
Wenn Sie Ihre Beine hoch machen,
dann macht man die Schmerzen.
Nein, das macht keinen Unterschied.
Wenn die Schmerzen da sind,
dann muss ich einfach aufhören,
wenn Sie mich setzen,
dann ist es egal, ob ich mich hinsetze
oder meine Beine hochlage.
Okay.
Herr Hahn, haben Sie Fieber oder Stilfost?
Fieber oder Stilfost, nein, habe ich nicht.
nicht. Oder leiden Sie unter Schweiß oder Kalten Schweiß? Nein.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Gewichtsabstufe genommen?
Nichts Besonderes, also normal. Okay.
Ist bei Ihnen übel? Übelkeit habe ich nicht.
Mussten Sie sich übergeben? Nein.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder was erlassen?
Ne, wie immer, immer selber. Nichts Besonderes.
Okay. Herr Hahn, ich würde eine Vorerkrankung vorgestellt.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen wie Bluthoffdruck,
Suckerkrankheit oder von mathematischen Erkrankungen?
Römer habe ich nicht. Ich sage mal so, ich nehme Medikamente ein
von meinem Hausarzt wegen Bluthoffdruck und habe seit wann, seit zwei
Jahre, sorry, seit 20 Jahren. Okay. Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ramiepril nehme ich ein. Milligramm bis 10 Milligramm,
morgens und abends. Okay. Haben Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Ja, also da nehme ich noch Medikamente wegen Cholesterinerhöhung.
Ich habe zu viel Cholesterin im Blut. Haben Sie Fettsstoff,
Wechselstörungen? Ja, zu viel Cholesterin im Blut,
sagt mein Hausarzt. Und deswegen nehme ich Medikamente ein.
Wie heißt das? 20 Milligramm.
Da nehme ich abends eine Tablette.
Noch abends. Okay. Herr Hahn, sind Sie operiert worden?
Ja, in meiner Jugend wurde ich an Blindarm operiert.
Und in meiner Kindheit wurde ich an Mandeln operiert.
Können Sie sich erinnern, wann haben Sie sich berührt?
Wann, die Operiert? Ich weiß nicht, das war ungefähr,
ich glaube, 7 Jahre alt mit den Mandeln.
Und Blindarm war, denke ich, mal 16 Jahre alt.
Das ist ungefähr ein paar Tage her, ich bin nicht genau so erinnert.
Ja, alles klar. Ist bei Ihnen allergien gegen etwas?
Ja, damals, wo ich eine Mandeloperation hatte,
da haben die mir Penicillin gegeben.
Und da hatte ich allergisch reagiert, sagt man mir.
Also meine Mutter sagt das auch, seit der OP darf sie nicht mehr
Penicillin einnehmen. Ich hätte schlechte Atme.
Ich hätte weiteratmet.
Ich hätte schlechte Atmenprobleme gehabt.
Wie genau kann ich mich nicht erinnern?
Sonst andere Medikamente habe ich keine Allergien.
Ist es im Status oder wenn es Sie völlig geben?
Ja, ich habe alle auch Corona-Impfungen.
Ich denke schon, ein Ausfall habe ich jetzt nicht,
wo ich 1949 da geimpft war, aber meine Mutter sagt,
ich bin dann für alles geimpft und ich habe auch
mit meinem Erwachsenen alles geimpft lassen.
Okay, herrn.
Es ist so ein paar Tage her, Kinder immer,
weil sich meine Mutter alles gemacht hat.
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
Deswegen tragen manche Menschen Impfpasta bei.
Ja, aber mein Impfpasta ist nicht mehr so alt.
Der ist neuter Hausarzt.
Hat alles angekreuzt.
Wenn nirgendwo etwas ist, dann lasch mich impfen.
Auch bei Corona, ich bin schon viermal geimpft.
Corona.
Alles gut.
Ist bei, oder ist in ihrer Familie oder Eltern
chronische Erkrankungen bekannt, wie Bluthochdruck
oder ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ja, mein Vater hatte auch Bluthochdruckerkrankungen.
Und er hatte auch,
der ist am Herzenfang verstorben damals.
Mein Beileid.
Ja, das war schon lange her.
Also damals war er 80 Jahre alt und
ist am Herzenfang gestorben.
Der hatte Bluthochdruckerkrankungen.
Er hat Gefeßerkrankungen gehackt.
Achso, ja.
Achso, in Hessen sagen wir 80.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist mit 77 Jahren verstorben.
Die lebt auch nicht mehr.
Sie hatte, weiß ich nicht, ob das chronisch erkrankt.
Sie war übergewichtig.
Sie hatte Bluthochdruckerkrankungen.
Sie hatte Zuckererkrankungen.
Sie hatte Insulin gespritzt.
Sie hatte irgendeine Schildrüse,
eine Medikamente hat sie genommen.
Schildrüse Erkrankungen, aber weiß ich genau,
kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Schildrüse Medikamente.
Kann ich nicht sagen,
irgendwie Tyroxin oder sowas heißt das.
Ja, wie ich, Schildrüse, Super Funktion.
Und hat er sie geschwistert?
Geschwister, ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Er ist jünger als ich.
Ist er gesund?
Er nimmt auch Medikamente ein,
aber er hat nicht wie ich,
und wie mein Vater,
hat er keinen Bluthochdruckerkrankungen.
Ich glaube, der Arme hat, der ist übergewichtig.
Ich glaube, der nimmt auch wegen seiner Blutfette
oder Kolesterinsäcke, er nimmt auch ein.
Und der hat aber auch eine,
wie nennt man es, Stent in seinem Gefäß.
Also ein Herz.
Er hat eine Katheteruntersuchung gehabt.
Ansonsten ist er gesund, der ist fitter als ich.
Ah, gut, okay.
Trotz dieser Vorgeschichte.
Herr Hahn, rauchen Sie?
Ich hatte früher mal geraucht,
aber jetzt auch ich nicht.
Ich hatte etwa 30 Jahre lang geraucht
und habe vor 20 Jahren aufgehört.
Ich habe mit 20 bis 53 Lebensjahre geraucht.
Danach habe ich gesagt, ich werde damit auch.
Ich habe das seit 20 Jahren nicht geraucht.
Wie viele Zigarette haben Sie geraucht?
Das war schon eine Packung pro Jahr.
Pro Tag war das schon.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, ja.
Abends ein Glas Wein trinke ich schon.
Ich mache das gerne zum Essen.
Ja, in der Abend.
Nein, ich würde sagen, 2-3 Mal die Woche.
Ein Glas Wein, kann man so sagen.
Nicht viel, sonst trinke ich kein Alkohol.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Droge?
Droge?
Wir machen Sie Witze, ich nehme doch keine Drogen ein.
Ja, könnte sein.
Nein, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie Drogen geschrieben wird.
Okay, gut.
Herr Hahn, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin jetzt aktuell Panzer näher.
Vorher war ich Polizeibeamter.
Polizeibeamter.
Ja, bitte.
Sehr streng, denn da war ich nicht mehr.
Ich habe noch ein paar Jahre lang mitgekommen.
Sehr streng, denn da war ich noch ein paar Jahre lang mitgekommen.
Ja, das war ein bisschen angeregt.
Das stimmt schon, wenn man mit Menschen zu tun hat,
ist es wie bei Ihrem Beruf, wenn man mit Menschen zu tun hat,
dann ist es mal so, mal so, nicht einfach.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Hahn?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Sind Sie gesund?
Ich denke schon, ich wusste nicht, dass die Medikamente einnehmen.
Also, Sie sind gesund.
Ja, gut.
Wohnen Sie alleine?
Mit meiner Frau.
Mit meiner Frau, die Kinder sind schon verheiratet.
Der eine so ein Kind ist verheiratet,
der andere lebt mit seiner Freundin zusammen.
Okay, Herr Hahn.
Ich habe eine wichtige Frage aus meinerseits gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, was soll ich da hinzufügen?
Ich bin ja hier umfangen,
aber ich weiß nicht, dass ich jetzt wüsste,
was man noch dazu fügen sollte.
Aber meine Frage wäre, wie geht es jetzt weiter, Frau Doktor?
Was machen Sie mit mir?
Was habe ich für eine Erkrankung?
Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Ja, ich meine, bisher,
nach bisherigen Angaben,
gehe ich von den Knäuschen
Probleme aus.
Was meinst du?
Minisküs Probleme.
Minisküs Probleme, okay.
Aber jetzt kann ich nicht genau sagen,
weil wir machen erstmal körperliche Untersuchungen.
Dann möchte ich Sie von Ihnen
erst mal über die Erkrankung,
die Sie haben,
dann möchte ich Sie von Ihnen
etwas Diagnostik
und Massnahmen durchführen.
Dann, wenn ich alle Ergebnisse bekomme,
können wir nochmal darüber besprechen.
Okay.
Dann legen Sie mal los.
Sie können im Waldesamt,
im Alkazema,
Plastik nehmen.
Ich werde wieder aufrufen.
Okay, danke Frau Doktor.
Ich habe klassische Frage.
Haben Sie Top House Gefühle,
Krippen, Kraftlosigkeit in Rehtembein?
Hab ich nicht.
Ich trage auch die Schmerzen
in andere Regionen aus.
Ja, so mein Unterschenkel.
Wenn ich starke Schmerzen habe,
ziehen die Schmerzen in meinen Unterschenkel.
Wenn Sie die Schmerzen generell beschreiben,
dann sind Sie eher dumm.
Sie haben gesagt,
bei Belastung,
auf der Treppe in die Schmerzen,
treppen oder absteigen?
Ja, in den Treppen steigen ist schlimmer.
Aber aufsteigen,
das Treppen tut auch weh.
Aber runterlaufen ist schlimmer.
Muss immer vorsichtig sein.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie noch eine Frage?
Ja, haben Sie
ein Überwarnung?
Ein bisschen schon, ja.
Das ist leicht wärmer als
Hautfarbfänderung.
Also ist es nicht gerötet.
Aber ein bisschen wärmer als das linke Knie.
Noch eine Frage, Kollege.
Sein Hücham.
Sonst muss ich fragen, ob es noch etwas gibt?
Wenn es nicht gibt,
dann muss ich sagen,
ich habe nicht sehr viel Kraft.
Muss man vielleicht genauer fragen,
sind diese Kraftverlust wegen den Schmerzen
oder ist es einfach nur Kraftlosigkeit?
Sie haben nicht mehr die Kraft,
weil man kann auch eine Kraft
beeilen.
Das ist eine Parise.
Muskelkraft.
Es ist die Sensibilität.
Haben Sie Taubplatzgefühl?
Haben Sie Empfindungen?
Haben Sie Krümpel?
Im Unterchenkel oder im Fuß?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Das ist eine Parise.
Vorher haben wir die Fragen,
die gefragt wurden.
Wie ist der Schmerzcharakter?
Ist es knieüberwärmt?
Die ganzen Fragen,
die es mit dieser Region zu tun hat.
Erst fragen,
dann übergehen, wo man sagt,
man kann nachher etwas ergänzen.
Aber vorher, wenn das fertig ist, dann kann man sagen so, dann würde ich gerne noch generell
Anamnese nehmen, wie, ob sie Vorerkrankungen haben, ob sie familiäre Belastungen haben,
weil Vorerkrankungen würde ich gerne spezielle Fragen, was ihr immer generell weiter war.
Später kann man immer noch sagen, ah, ich habe noch eine spezielle Frage vergessen.
Wie war das noch mehr mit der G-Strecke? Haben Sie eine G-Strecke in Winderung?
Sie können auch etwas zu tun, wenn sie spezielle Anamnese haben.
Das ist dann systematisch.
Das ist schon ein wichtiges Problem, die Sie schon haben.
Das ist ein System, das sich in der Kopf schälen kann.
Ich bin bereit.
Ja, hallo.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, hat in der Zeit.
Natürlich, deswegen bring ich da, schießen Sie los.
Okay, der 73-jährige Patient
stellte sich wegen den Schmerzen in rechten Kniegelenk
mit Ausstrahlung zu unter Schlenk vor.
Unter Schenkel, meinst du, Schenkel?
Unter Schenkel.
Ja, und die Schmerzen haben seit sechs Monaten angenommen.
Angenommen?
Nein, sie meinen, die Schmerzen haben seit zwei Jahren angefangen.
Angefangen.
Und sind seit einigen Wochen zu nehmen.
Und der Patient beschrieb, die Schmerzen als sichende Schmerzen.
Was?
Sichende?
Sichend.
Ja, ziehend.
Und der Patient berichtete, dass er Schwellung bemerkhaft
und auch Überwärmung in betroffenen Gebiet bemerkhaft.
Hatte, habe er bemerkt?
Ja, habe.
Sie hatte keinen Unfall.
Sie, er berichtete, dass...
Sie hatte keinen Unfall, ist es ein Erd oder eine Sie?
Er, er berichtete...
dass er keinen Unfall habe?
Dass er keinen Unfall habe.
Und die Schmerzen seien belastungabhängig.
Der Patient habe dagegen Beibetal überprüfen eingenommen,
aber sei es ihnen nicht geholfen, seit ein Wochen.
Haben die Schmerzen sich ein bisschen gelindert durch das Medikament?
Ein bisschen gelindert, aber seit einigen Wochen,
sind die Schmerzen da überhaupt.
Okay, okay.
Der Patient gab an, dass ihre Beine, oder ihre betroffene Beine
nicht gebeugt werden.
Noch mal?
Ja, noch mal.
Dass er ihre Beine nicht gebeugt, nicht gebeugen konnte.
Welches Gelenk geht das nicht, das Bein?
Das rechte Knie, könnte er nicht beugen.
Er ist nicht mehr ein Kniegelenk.
Er habe Probleme bei der Beugung, im rechten Kniegelenk zum Beispiel.
Oder eine Bewegungseinschränkung bei der Beugung.
Kann man auch sagen, kann man so und so alles sagen.
Bei Hochlage ist bei ihm nicht geholfen.
Eine Hochlage um das Bein ist, rechten Beine,
helfen ihm nicht.
Zum Beispiel, kann man sagen.
Okay.
Begle, die vegetative Anamnese sind unauffällig.
Hat er eine Lehmungserscheinung?
Ja, Entschuldigung.
Er hat berichtet, dass er Missempfindung,
oder Krüg-Misempfindung haben.
Und Krüg-Misempfindung?
Nicht habe.
Er hatte es nicht.
Entschuldigung, ich habe verpasst.
Er habe keine Lehmung.
Sehen so motorische Ausfälle.
Also keine Parisen, keine Krügel, keine.
Okay.
Die vegetative Anamnese sind unauffällig.
An Vorerkrankungen sind eine Bluthoffdruck bekannt,
seit 20 Jahren.
Er nehme dagegen, regelmäßig,
20 mg, einmal morgen und einmal abends.
Und sie musted in, 20 mg,
abends eingenommen.
An Voroperationen sind appendectomy und
Tonsylektromie bekannt.
Der Patient hat allerging gegen Penicillin.
Das äußert sich Luftnot oder Disple.
An Vorerkrankungen sind einen Bluthoffdruck.
Sein Vater hatte Bluthoffdruck und
ist an Myokardinfarktriusis gestorben.
Seine Mutter hatte auch Bluthoffdruck und
Adipositas.
Und sie ist gestorben.
Aber er, glaube ich,
Haben Sie nicht gefragt?
Ja.
Aber der Sohn, warum wusste es nicht?
Kein Problem.
Ja, deswegen wollte ich sagen,
er wente nicht,
Er wurde nicht erwähnt,
an was sie gestorben sei, zum Beispiel.
Okay.
Er hat, er habe einen Bruder,
der an Fettstoffwechselstörungen leidet.
Leider.
Er ist die Personier von Beruf.
Er ist Isenta.
Er, er meint sie, er der Bruder,
weil sie gesagt haben, der Bruder,
der, der ist der Bruder, der ist der Bruder.
Der Patient ist jetzt Rentner,
aber vorher habe er Polizeibeamte gearbeitet.
Die Beamten sind Pensionäre, nicht Rentner.
Pensionäre.
Pensionäre sind Beamte.
Und Arbeiter sind Rentner.
Zum Beispiel.
Okay.
Dass man das Wort hört, Pensionäre.
Sie sei verheiratet und habe zwei Söhne.
Sie ist unser, Sie, ah, ich lege, ich lege,
ich habe immer,
alles klar, kein Problem.
Der Patient ist verheiratet
und habe zwei Söhne.
Und er lebe mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Ja, nach,
nach dieser, nach dieser Panamese
Fragen nehme ich von
Konathrose aus.
Gehe ich nochmal, nochmal den Satz bilden bitte.
Nach Mistergen,
Anamese,
Gespräch,
nach Gergeseinem Angaben.
Gehe ich von Konathrose aus.
Okay, gut.
Aber es könnte auch
peripherartig
eine Venösekrankheit sein.
Venösekrankheit.
Wie kommen Sie daher?
Warum sagen Sie da
Venösekrankheit?
Was leitet Sie dahin?
Weil dort eine Schwellung ist, sagen Sie.
Im Knie ist geschwollen.
Ist der Unterchekel auch geschwollen?
Ja.
Nein, der Unterchekel war nicht geschwollen, nur das Knie.
Aber Sie sehr beschwollen?
Also fast nicht dazu.
Aber was könnte man sonst denken?
Ich komme Sie eigentlich nicht genau.
Die Transiodiagnose finden.
Vorhin haben Sie eine Diagnose genannt.
Ganz vor den Patienten.
Miniscous lesion.
Miniscopatie könnte sein.
Miniscous degeneratio.
Genau.
Es könnte auch eine Atritis sein.
Ein akuter Gichtanfall.
Ja, stimmt.
Es könnte auch sein.
Gichtatritis.
Es könnte vielleicht nicht bekannt vorher sein.
Es könnte auch rheumatische Genese sein.
Man weiß es nicht.
Okay.
Dann.
Ja, jemand hat gesagt, eine BKZ-Struktur.
Kann es auch sein.
Bandrupter.
Ist kein Trauma bekannt.
Kann natürlich sein, aber wenig.
Das reicht eigentlich.
Wie gehen Sie voran?
Sie haben jetzt eine Arbeitssyplothese.
Eine Diagnose.
Was würden Sie jetzt machen, damit Sie das bestätigen?
Um meine Verdastagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich Folgendem Ausnahmen durchführen.
Erst mal mache ich eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Das ist gut.
Ich würde nur sagen, es hört sich besser an, wenn man sagt,
erst mal würde ich eine ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Ausführliche.
Ist immer besser.
Ja.
Hört sich schöner an.
Ja, stimmt.
Mach ich eine ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung.
Ja.
Und veranlässe ich einen Dröntgen.
Weitzeitig im Kniegelenk.
Ja.
Was würden Sie, ich habe Sie verstanden.
Die Satzbau ist ein bisschen falsch, aber die geht jetzt in die Richtung.
Was würden Sie auf die Röntgenanförderung schreiben,
wenn Sie es schreiben müssten?
Machen Sie das Röntgen oder lassen Sie das veranlassen?
Röntgen.
Ja. Machen Sie die Röntgen-Untersuchung
oder lassen Sie das jemand anderem machen?
Ja, lassen ich.
Also, was machen Sie, wenn Sie veranlassen?
Eine Röntgen-Untersuchung.
Wenn Sie eine Antwortung schreiben,
Sie als Notfallambulanzärztin
und sagen, sagen Sie, hey, Radiologe, mach mal Röntgen
oder hat es eine Form?
Ja, eine Form.
Ja, genau. Da steht es, drehen Sie meistens am Computer.
Röntgen, Kniegelenk in zwei Ebenen.
Diesen Wort können Sie auswendig lernen.
Es ist egal, wo das ist.
Das ist das, das ist das.
Wenn Sie sagen, ich veranlasse eine Röntgenaufnahme
des Kniegelenkes rechts in zwei Ebenen
oder ich veranlasse Röntgen-Kniegelenk rechts in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen, Handgelenk rechts in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen, Torachs rechts in zwei Ebenen
bei Rippenfrakturen.
Röntgen, LWS in zwei Ebenen.
Immer das Wort Röntgen,
dann das Organ in zwei Ebenen.
Und vielleicht noch rechts, links.
So kann man sagen, auswendig lernen, immer dieses Modus
und dann kann man sagen, ich kann den Satz ein bisschen ändern.
Röntgen, ich veranlasse,
nach der ausführlichen, körperlichen Untersuchung
veranlasse ich eine Röntgenaufnahme des rechten Kniegelenk
in zwei Ebenen, zum Beispiel.
Punkt, jetzt wiederholen Sie bitte.
Ich veranlasse Röntgenaufnahme
in rechten Kniegelenk in zwei Ebenen.
Ebenen, genau.
Gut.
Auf keg Ebenenfalls.
Bleiben wir erstmal bei Röntgenaufnahme.
Was würden Sie dort erwarten,
wenn Sie eine Atrose sehen?
Ja, ich erwarte die Generation
oder Schädigung des Kniegelenk.
Genau.
Wie äußert sich das?
Was würden Sie zum Beispiel, was ist ein Zeichen einer Generation?
Die Verengung des Abstands.
Richtig.
Man sagt auch Verschmählerung, schmal werden.
Verschmählerung des Gelenkspaltes.
Genau, Gelenkspaltes.
Richtig.
Was ist noch ein Zeichen?
Auch könnte es aus der Vite sehen.
Genau, Osteofütiere anbauten,
anbauen, kann man erkennen.
Genau.
Und vielleicht noch eine,
oder Sie noch,
was kann man noch?
Schädigung.
Ja, Knopel,
Subschondrale,
Subschondrale Züstenbildung zum Beispiel.
Kann man manchmal sehen.
Oder eine subschondrale Sklerosierung,
Verdichtung.
Das ist eine Subschondrale Sklerosierung.
Das reicht.
Eigentlich schon die zwei Reichen schon.
Was Sie gesagt haben, das ist okay.
So, sagen wir mal, im Röntgen haben wir das jetzt nicht festgestellt.
Ja.
Was würden Sie dann veranlassen?
Dann würde ich MRT durchführen.
Lassen, genau.
MRT durchführen lassen.
MRT des rechten Kniegelenkens durchführen lassen.
Genau.
Richtig.
Okay.
Falls Sie eine fortgeschrittene Arthrose festgestellt haben,
mit Gelenkspalt Aufhebung, also Verschmählerung,
wenn es nicht mehr gibt, nennt man auch Gelenkspalt Aufhebung.
Kalmer Masse, gerne.
Geh mir die Aufhebung.
Falls Sie sowas sehen,
das ist eine Sperrflugung,
falls Sie sowas sehen und eine Destruktion des Kniegelenkens.
Würden Sie trotzdem einen MRT machen wollen?
Eigentlich ja, würde ich machen,
weil ich würde Bande oder Menüs gesehen,
weil MRT mit dieser Untersuchung können,
kann ich auch weicher Gewicht beurteilen.
Nicht Gewicht, sondern weiche Teile.
Weiche Teile beurteilen.
Theoretisch ja, haben Sie recht.
Aber wenn jemand keinen Gelenkspalt aufhebt,
dann ist bestimmt Chondropathie da,
dann ist bestimmt Meniskusdekoneration da,
weil das eine fortgeschrittene Arthrose ist,
da ist alles kaputt.
Man kann ja nicht MRT machen.
Man kann, ergänzt sind, kann man schon machen.
Man würde wahrscheinlich sehen,
dass da Ödem in den Knochen ist und so weiter.
Aber man kann vielleicht andere Sachen ausschließen,
was man nicht im Grenzen sieht.
Zum Beispiel einige Tumore,
die man vielleicht in der Renn genießt, kann man auch machen.
Ich persönlich würde nicht gleich direkt ein MRT machen.
Ich würde therapieren, wenn es nicht besser wird,
oder bevor ich eine Operation machen würde,
kann man, damit man eine Plan-Sicherheit hat,
ein MRT machen.
Das war eine persönliche Meinung.
Ich würde nicht gleich ein MRT machen.
Kann man machen, schadet nicht.
MRT ist ja nicht schädlich, kostet nur Geld.
Okay, dann gehen wir davon aus.
Dieser Mann hat eine leicht geradige Arthrose.
Wie würde die Diagnose heißen?
Äh, gonathrose.
Ich will noch ein Wort dazu hören.
Das stimmt, das ist richtig.
Das ist mal gehört.
Sagt dann eine aktivierte gonathrose.
Die ist aktiv, entsündlich geworden.
Manche Leute haben eine gonathrose,
und die haben keinen Schmerz.
Die genaerationen.
Aber wenn er mit warmem Knie kommt,
mit einem Erguss kommt,
und er hat Schmerzen,
dann ist es eine entsündlich gewordene gonathrose.
Man sagt dann im Deutschen, es ist eine aktivierte gonathrose.
Aktivierte gonathrose.
Ja, aktivierte coxathrose, aktivierte gonathrose.
Aber viele Kollegen,
Autofenotofallschrungen, schreiben nur,
Diagnose gonathrose rechts.
Aber wenn man genauer nimmt,
ist es eine, weil es ja entsündlich geworden ist
und dick und arbeitet, das Knie.
Also es ist entsündlich geworden,
also es ist eine aktivierte gonathrose.
Die ist aktuell aktiv.
Die Patient akute Beschwerden.
Genau, dass er akute Beschwerden hat mit der gonathrose.
Der Mensch hat jetzt eine leichtgradige gonathrose,
aber die ist aktiv.
Was würden Sie Therapie empfehlen?
Erstmal würde ich Schmerzmittel geben.
Zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel...
Unser Hauptmedikament,
unser orthopedischer Standardmedikament.
Genau, was ist das ein?
NSHR.
Antheraumatisch?
Genau.
Das muss nicht Ibuprofen sein,
oder Ibuprofen in Wolfaren,
Arcox, C.
NSHR würde ich geben.
Das ist wichtiger für die Therapie,
damit die Enzyme weniger wird.
Wenn es nicht ausreicht,
kann man das ergänzen.
Zum Beispiel,
man kann zusätzlich etwas Medikamentes geben.
Der Patient nimmt Ibuprofen sowieso.
Ibuprofen dreimal am Tag,
für 3-5 Tage.
Aber es reicht nicht.
Da kann man auch Schmerzen.
Was kann man sonst machen?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich jetzt...
Ja, kann man machen,
das ist die übernächste Stufe.
Man würde noch Novalgien geben.
Genau.
Novalgien geben,
wenn das nicht reicht,
dann Ibuprofen in die Richtung.
Tramal-Tilidin, das ist eine Vorstufe.
Wenn das nicht reicht,
dann noch zusätzlich Morphine
oder andere Obfiete geben.
Das ist die eine Möglichkeit.
Der Patient sagt,
mein Kniegelenk ist stark geschwollen.
Was kann man sonst machen?
Dass die Schwellung weniger schnell weggeht.
Ja, Artroscentese.
Artroscentese, man sieht es.
Was ist das? Artrose?
Artroscentese.
Was heißt das?
Was war das?
Wenn ein Druck...
Ein Druck...
...gekalt, genau.
Brust sich abnehmen.
Aber...
Funktionen.
Kniefunktionen.
Man würde eine Kniefunktion durchführen
und den Erguss rausnehmen.
Wenn man eine Funktion macht,
kann man etwas machen.
Wenn man die Nadel reinsticht,
man könnte das andere
Entzündungshermene-Medikament-Gruppe geben.
Wenn es eine NSAR gibt,
dann gibt es auch einen SAR.
Man kann es zum Beispiel reingehen.
Also, nicht Cortison haben Sie an Theorematik,
aber man kann auch Cortison geben.
Man muss den Patienten aber aufklären.
Über die Risiken.
Das wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Bei den Patienten,
der eine leichtbereitige Artrose hat,
würde ich trotzdem ein MRT machen.
Weil der leichtbereitige Artrose hat.
Weil es kann ein Miniskusproblem sein.
Man kann ja vielleicht mit Atroskopien
oder irgendwelchen operativ Maßnahmen helfen.
Jetzt gehe ich zurück.
Eigentlich muss man überlegen,
als Therapie gibt es immer zwei Wege.
Eine Seite konservative Therapie,
die andere Seite operative Therapie.
Bei einer leichtbereitigen Artrose
muss man sich konservative Maßnahmen versuchen.
Wie Medikamentgabe, Physiotherapie,
Kylotherapie, also Kühlung.
Das ist auch eine Maßnahme.
Schonung, dass es nicht zu viel laufen soll.
Das nötige.
Und wenn diese Maßnahmen nicht eventuell
Funktion des Kniegelenkens.
Und wenn diese Maßnahmen nicht helfen,
kann man ein MRT machen,
um zu entscheiden,
ob man eine operative Therapie empfehlen kann.
Vorhin hat einer eine Diagnose gesagt,
eine eitrige Eitrizis.
Denke ich eher nicht,
weil der kein Fieber hatte zum Beispiel.
Das war auch kein Fieber.
Keine Rötung,
sondern nur leichter werden.
Bei einer eitrigen Entzündung
kriegt man meistens,
nicht immer, aber meistens Fieber
und meistens haben die auch eine Rötung des Kniegelenkens.
Aber bei alten Menschen kann man manchmal anders sein.
Stimmt schon.
Also, was ich sagen wollte bei der Therapie,
konservativ und operativ.
Auch bei Fraktur, wenn einer ein Handgelenkensfraktur hat,
kann man sagen,
man kann konservativ und operativ therapieren.
Ist die Fraktur disloziert,
würde ich eine operative Vorgehen empfehlen.
Wenn es nicht disloziert ist,
würde ich eine konservative Maßnahme mit Schienen
und später mit einer Gipsversorgung, Rückstellung empfehlen.
Wer ist empfehlen?
Der Patient muss mal aufgeklärt sein,
ob diese Dislocation,
wenn er sagt, es ist disloziert,
aber ich will mich nicht operieren.
Der wird nicht sterben,
sondern hat den Fakt,
wo man operieren muss oder irgendwas eingreifen.
Da muss man sagen, der Bruch kann nicht heilen,
dann haben sie wahrscheinlich wieder Schmerzen,
Bewegungseinschränkungen usw.
Deswegen erzähle ich immer, wie empfehlen wir.
Wenn eine Fraktur ist,
wir können nur anladen,
meine Empfehlung ist dringend,
eine dringende Empfehlung wäre bei der Situation,
dass wir operieren.
Ich will nur, dass ihr hört,
dass wir empfehlen, konservativ operativ.
Meistens immer versuchen wir,
konservativ, wenn nicht,
Gewichtsabnahme, der Herr ist 6 Nacht zu viel.
Aber der Patient ist normal, ich denke.
Der Patient ist nicht übergewicht.
Ja, 6 Nachts, nicht sehr übergewichtig, das stimmt schon.
Aber man kann erwähnen,
es würde gut sein,
dass man versuchen kann, Gewicht abzunehmen.
Was schwierig ist,
ist ein Hochalter.
Also ich in meinem Alter kann nicht so leicht abnehmen,
weil man nicht will,
weil man lieber ist.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, alles klar für mich.